so before we announce the three winners
I want to invite Paul Jaffe from the
Naval Research Lab who will announce the
semi-finalists for the DoD competition
special prize surprise Thank You Senate
the introduction as I mentioned I'm Paul
Jaffe from the u.s. Naval Research
Laboratory and I am here is the
representative from the Department of
Defense and looking at energy projects
with regard to their applicability for
Department of Defense needs so it's no
surprise I'm sure to you to know that a
lot of pain and danger goes into
providing energy to our forces and those
that work to to keep us safe and that
fight for our country as a result
there's a DoD prize track and the three
teams that have been selected here will
go on to the final competition there
were a couple requirements for the DoD
prize the first was that a team must
have a prototype of whatever their
innovation or technology is and that it
should address the key driver of
reducing mass and volume of the energy
supplies that we need to move forward it
also needs to be easy-to-use able to be
rapidly deployed and durable so to this
end there were three teams that
exhibited a addressing these needs the
first one I'm pleased to say is waste
list tech from Penn State good have a
team representing up for a moment
so as you saw from their presentation
waste lists X innovation reduces the
volume of water this eunice if you can
imagine just like cutting down ideally
by 90% the number of tanks tanker trucks
full of water that we might have to
bring forward would be great
the second team is grapefruit from CMU
their approach to monitoring controlling
and potentially reducing energy that's
used in theater is very valuable again
any amount of fuel that we can reduce is
important for DoD and perhaps most
important and we actually hear this like
I hear this when I talk to the Marines
and the army they say you know we have a
real problem we can't even monitor how
much energy we're using and where we're
using it so the innovation from grid
fruit is a really good step towards
doing that for for our forces so
congratulations so then the final team
in the defense track is square line
power from West Virginia University
their innovation allows soldiers to
potentially easily recharge equipment
without it's getting dirty without
requiring bulky power cabling that is
prone to failure and it also offers a
promise potentially of a drone that you
could recharge without having to plug it
in or to unplug it so is there anyone
still here from square line power all
right well if you would accept it on
their behalf that would be fantastic so
in as many many of you are having
exposure now to to wireless power as a
thing in the consumer world obviously
there's applications for DoD as well so
great thank you okay the winners of the
prototype fries and the 2500 also
developed their prototypes are boundary
labs Case Western wind turbine drag
reduction tomato announced all of them
together yeah a great food from Carnegie
Mellon intelligence software for
commercial building refrigeration expiry
ml Carnegie Mellon artificial
intelligence for better batteries the
fan favorite oh sorry oh yeah
[Applause]
oh but these guys are too tall
[Laughter]
[Applause]
fan-favorite winner of $5,000 prize is
köppen state solar cell technology team
from Colton state investor Marilyn
[Applause]
yeah we're under center
[Music]
[Applause]
so the surprise third place for the
Allegheny region clean tech competition
and winner of $5,000 price boundary lab
from Case Western
[Applause]
thank you
second place and winner of $10,000 prize
echo tone from Carnegie Mellon
[Applause]
first place and winner of $50,000 prize
waste less technology from Penn State
[Applause]
okay
so that ends the Allegheny region
competition and I will turn podium to
Anna to introduce the next